5 55 on your monday morning what's
driving
crazy well what a difference a year
makes
kind of hoping that the pedestrian
bridge grand opening we showed last week
in the southwest valley
might have at least sounded vaguely
familiar because we featured that
groundbreaking for the project
right here on what's driving you crazy
in march of last year
going to make it easier to get to and
from desert oasis
to the residential neighborhoods nearby
without having to go up
rainbow over to cactus and then around
so the pedestrian bridge going in on
rainbow just south of
erie will cross over the union pacific
railroad tracks onto or near the school
property
well it sure was windy last thursday
when commissioner jones and staff and
students from desert oasis were the
first ones to walk across
that pedestrian bridge for commissioner
justin jones of course and with that
bridge the far
southwest and the far northwest may
eventually link up to close the loop on
what's called
the vegas valley rim trail that's where
bicyclists and even walkers
might be able to cover a giant track
around most of urbanized southern nevada
as we know it today all this information
is on our website eightnewsnow.com when
you click traffic and what's driving you
crazy buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone if there's something
driving you crazy email me traffic eight
eight newsnow.com